hello
cool awesome hi guys how's it going
all right um so not i think we're aware
that not everyone knows
uh why we're here what this is
um but we used to be a a fun
podcast about javascript and front-end
development um
in fact no big deal but um brennan ike
did start his 2011 java uh jsconf eu
keynote with um so i was watching yakuri
the other day
so not too bad no big deal no big deal
we were also one of the top two podcasts
focusing on jquery
also one of the only two podcasts
focusing on jquery from
2009 until 2011 very popular among
people who watched podcasts about jquery
and this year we got invited to this
year's jsconf after being the lunchtime
entertainment at the 2010.
the notes say 11 but i knew that was
wrong uh
so you shouldn't expect to learn a whole
lot because we're
really more about being stupid
but so obviously for those of you who
aren't up to speed
uh on what we do we um
we've compiled kind of a greatest hits
montage
uh of you know our
greatest hits uh
so um that's uh we're gonna roll that
for you right now
after we give you a little background uh
oftentimes adam
would either just nail a segway or just
really bomb them
and so i'm glad you guys were able to
get a taste of him really bombing one
uh so a little background on uh
how this starts uh a lot of people saw
this in the show but we never get the
background on it so we thought we'd give
some behind-the-scenes
info uh okay so clap
is like our ether pad that we use and a
lot of people actually you've probably
seen something on
ok so clap before in the first episode
i was the editor and for a few i was the
really bad quality ones
and uh paul every time he would start a
sentence he'd like
okay so and he'd clap his hands uh and i
just got really tired of it so i
registered the domain
and gifted it to him so we ended up
using that uh as the way we would sync
audio in the beginning of episodes so
that's the story behind okay so clap and
how our montage
starts montage sound
uh we should do a uh clappy club maybe
yeah whatever sure alex
paul adam
perfect
uh
uh this is not the jquery podcast but
instead this is the
yay
query the yay query podcast uh
so we just basically wanted to have a
very casual conversation about what's
going on in the jquery and front-end
development community
i think it might be time for a segment
that we like to call the vlog
if you missed it last year jsconf 2010
is on the horizon we loved paul and i
were at this conference and i think
everybody here has actually
signed up already because it was just
the best conference of the year
this year you want to talk
on a yay query party line
this is michael taylor are you saying
there's a map method on a jquery object
and there's also a map method just
on the jquery uh the jquery namespace
itself
much like after and before columbus's
voyage to the new world
there are two different maps that we're
working with here
um and i think we're gonna leave you
with that uh along with our best
turkey impressions and a jonathan neal
song
ultimately at its core it's just
javascript and what we're focusing on
is making javascript the first class
language that it is right well anyway 13
is like
it's more than 10 so i think that's
worth talking about
it's not 13 it's more than 10.
speaking of jonathan neal
in addition to console.log there's also
console.dir
d-i-r and
console.d-i-r we found
the complete bunnies guide to jquery
that's what we're calling it because we
can't read japanese that or
jquery for bunnies or uh i think it's
time for the
plugin
it's really really great
adam's you're still going yep no totally
still going
we don't have to finish those
uh sencha ext foundation or whatever
they are i don't know
ext core inner international uh
they are now sencha we have
tonight with us peter higgins and he
is going to help us bring in a new
segment that we are going to call
nate queery yay
query
so i was watching the food network this
weekend i wasn't watching the food
network this weekend but there's a show
called
throwdown throwdown and right now that's
what me and paul are going to have
[ __ ]
welcome to the 13th episode of the yay
query podcast
proud attenders of the 2010 js
conf we're going to hop right into our
favorite segment
it's the it
things you is thought you'd see
this week's hit enhancement is the event
constructor
didn't know it existed earlier well now
you do var
event equals new jquery.event capital e
because it's a constructor you can throw
at anything
what's it good for nobody knows what's
next adam
so john i'd like to ask you if you would
could you name 10 reserved words in
javascript for us please
um well
so we did not know about this john
i didn't even know that so was an
operator in javascript
let's get to the content guys that was
very
emblematic of what jsconf is
which is just crazy so
if you get a chance next year check it
out it is it is a wild
and fun weekend pandemonium pandemonium
we're joined tonight by our good friend
ralph
holtzman we wanted to tell you about
let's just call it let's just call it
the plug-in of the
of the plug-in
that was that was really weak guys let's
try again
i thought it was awesome
um i thought you were going to play the
music oh
no that happened music in post sometimes
i thought he would still play it for us
right now do you want to have a
sing-along
no it's cool okay so let me just tell
you about sausage uh someone asked what
uh crockford's opinion on js hint was
and he said something along the lines of
uh
people will always want to do stupid
things and luckily for those people
there's js hint what's that word like
the
something that sounds like what it's
onomatopoeia the word is what it
no that's
very wrong absolutely not bam that's
wrong
yay jsconf um chris williams put this on
last year and it was just
amazing and we're all gonna be there
this year and we can't wait
so sign up everybody have a yay of a
time until
jsconf and we'll get you some of our
backlogged videos
up now that we're sober again so hurrah
awesome peace out
is
i'll never do that again um so you guys
may have figured out
by now that there's no backlog of
podcasts
um but uh you know
ultimately we're really proud because
what we realized was we kind of kicked
off
a new generation of uh content where
people could just delve into whatever
they wanted so we obviously saw
you know the first take on this was the
uh the nay query
segment with pete um but then we were
really surprised
to find out that um then there was the
nay query starring the fruit strike
zebra and
you know that's where horse js got his
start um
and then from there it really started
taking off our our canadian
our canadian friends
got involved so the crazy thing about
this is then it really started going
viral because uh darcy clark
wasn't the only darcy clark who wanted
to get in on this
turns out there's a bodybuilder named
darcy clark
um and he and a female bodybuilder a
protein shake and then just
pile of whey protein started wayquery
um and the scripps howard network owners
of the food network
realized that like inanimate objects uh
just
talking for 30 minutes was a great great
content idea so that's where they did um
filet query
uh ben yay query uh chicken satay query
and of course uh then three crustaceans
and a super computer joined together for
cray query
and i know what you guys are all
thinking that shit's cray
but that [ __ ] what's really cray is
kanye query
but you know ultimately kanye query
turned out to be kind of shitty and you
kind of wanted to wash yourself
afterwards
so that's why there was bidet query
but then i showed that to my grandmother
and she was like
oh they query
um and we but we knew we were gonna
start to jump the shark when like the
mainstream entertainment kind of got
involved and um a whip
wax a tie and 50 actual shades of gray
joined for
50 shades of grey query and then
hollywood got in on the action with of
course
michael bay query and you know
we had you know this really just goes on
and on we have at least
20 unused shitty jokes uh
but we're gonna we're gonna turn this on
its head
and um go back to our roots from
jsconf2010
and uh do a game show it's uh
it's game time cool
so uh we did a game show uh where we
called like
groups of 10 up last time during lunch
and everyone's trying to eat and they're
like god leave us alone
but we were in there and you couldn't
really ignore us and so this time
uh we're going to let you stay in your
seats and
you're going to be able to vote with
your phones or you can
use your internet connected device um in
order to vote so
um do we have a url do i say that yet i
don't know i don't remember the order
i'm sorry
so sorry so basically um
bootstrap has obviously taken off like
gangbusters the last couple years
uh and uh jacob thornton fat uh
obviously the maintainer of that
you know great personality great guy so
we decided to put together
a game show called
did fat tweet that
um so uh if you follow
fat or even if you don't uh you know
you'll probably
be able to play along so here are the
rules we're gonna post the content of a
tweet
uh fat may or may not have tweeted it uh
you can go to pollyv.com
jquery uh each of the polls will have a
text code you can tweet to uh
text to 2233 or you can tweet the code
at poll
and the uh yeah way to go guys
um you must know someone at twitter uh
so
um we're gonna roll that do that right
now
and we'll give you like 15 30 seconds to
answer play some tunes
uh so the first one is kind of softball
you know whether or not you follow fat
uh just vote and we'll uh we'll see what
everyone thinks
oh
i'm doing it nice uh this one says i'm
really excited about the upcoming
bootstrap 3 release
congrats to all involved impeccable
grammar
a lot of fakes on this one all right
should we reveal
wait until let's wait till we get to
100. yeah
yeah that's the the critical mass all
right hundred results
it is fake it is fake uh yes
jacob would never tweet anything like
this uh
there's a capital there's an apostrophe
uh he mentioned
technology at all so
let's move on burritos are my family
let's uh
get some results for this ooh wow
this is the uh yakery dance theme dance
party theme i think
critical master 105 102 it's fake we got
you guys we just wanted to
to shake it up in the beginning so now
you don't know what to think so let's go
to the next one
what if pizza is uncomfortable with its
reputation
real or fake guys real or fake
oh wow very real i think some people are
on
jacob's twitter page
it's already critical math don't go
there
uh it's real all right next one
guys my new doctor uses linux
oh very neck and neck oh back to fake
real oh oh and it looks like
i'm gonna let it wait it out all right
all right yep it is real good
mainline general sews every day see how
far it got me
really fake
wow really take it up that was adam's i
believe
i think he i think he really nailed it
bandanas a lot of context there
i think we got you guys again all right
uh
holy [ __ ] baby corn isn't actually corn
what is real life even
wow all right wow that is real nice work
nice work
laying in bed alone eating smarties
period 27
no period oh
coming back no and we're re no yes it's
real
okay got a hat today twitter
i like the first person usage
104 it is real i gotcha worst tweet ever
am i right
ubuntu this is the last one guys so make
it count
and it looks like it's real it is real
good work everybody
good work looks like you guys got like
the crowd was 50 55
next segment
all right um so uh we had a segment
before
um and it was called uh let's see if i
can play this you want to play for me
it's like uh
come on you can put it on the actual
audio
oh yeah that's cool let's do that
oh it's not that one no come on
so this was one of our favorite segments
but uh we wanted to kind of like
summarize all the things that we learned
over the past few years and kind of
contextualize it and so
paul ash's jquery anti-pattern for
performance of the decade
is paul ash's anti-pattern for
performance
of the week um so basically uh i wanted
to
just apologize um i
i got caught up in like the shiny
performance optimizations the kinds of
things that you might see on js perf and
just like
uh really dig into those little micro
things that overall in the big picture
don't really teach a whole lot
demo demo all right rebecca said
you might not learn anything but we're
going to try something here so very
quickly
i just wanted to point out js when it
comes to a speed perspective especially
on web sites right js is often a small
fraction of the picture both on like
load time and on runtime
these are actually stats from when ie8
was released there was a good talk about
ie8 performance
um but this is as true as it as uh today
as it was then
they looked at like uh the amount of
javascript uh it was only contributing
to 33
of the time spent on the cpu on like
google
maps and gmail but i like regular
websites around 16
not a big deal um and so what i want to
do
is kind of show you uh a more realistic
view of overall performance so what i
have here is kind of this infographic-y
parallax site
i'm quickly going to scroll through it
just to kind of show you what it looks
like
so we got kind of this explosion thing
and then over here this little physics-y
dots that go
it's fun and then this action parallaxy
fun stuff and then i keep going down and
then there's these dots that kind of
explode all over the place
it's pretty cool but what i'm going to
do is go back to the very top
load up timeline and the chrome dev
tools and frames mode
start recording and then i'm just going
to scroll through the page again
same kind of deal but what you're seeing
on the bottom all these bars coming up
through
is that's giving me idea of the kinds of
operations that the browser is doing in
this whole
time
no i just hit close tab because
it seems normal
ouch all right frames mode
all right yeah still worked so what
we're looking at here is
kind of the performance as a narrative
of going through this operation
towards the beginning this green section
here uh is paint so we have really heavy
painting and this is as all these orange
bubbles are coming in then we go into a
bunch of yellow this is during the
physics
operation here this is actual javascript
being pretty heavy
then it's pretty chill in the middle for
the most part we're hitting our frame
budget
goals then down towards the bottom we
have this kind of
white explosion and there's kind of a
lot of operations including a good
amount of purple spent in here this is a
light time spent in layout but this
gives us a good view of kind of like all
the things that are going on
so that like for each segment there is
actually a specific
well there are predominant bottlenecks
and this gives a good idea of
how to adjust this paint here javascript
here and if we wanted to find out kind
of
what we could do for javascript i think
peter flynn from adobe showed this
just the other day record a cpu profile
and switch over to the new flame chart
and get a view
of over time kind of at each frame you
know what's the consistency of frames
here and what
are we looking at per frame uh this is
minified but you know
you get what i'm saying all right enough
uh
useful content let's go back to the show
all right
yeah so obviously as you may have seen
the the plugin of the week was one of
our
most cherished uh segments um
you know one mentioned on yayquery
plugin of the week pretty soon you have
like a
successful startup in a book deal true
wilson um
and uh but the thing is nowadays when
people release jquery plugins they end
up on hacker news and everyone's like yo
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
uh why would you bother like wrapping
some simple iteration sugar around like
something useful when you could be a
dick
and not do that
so as you can see uh you know here's a
hacker new search for why is this a
jquery plugin just a small snippet
um so that's why when we come up here to
jsconf we know everyone's really
sophisticated and if we're gonna tell
you about a plug-in
we want it to be something that's really
modular we want it to be something
that's useful
in uh you know a broad variety of
situations but most importantly we want
it to be something that inspires
thoughts of a romantic walk in the
enchanted woods
with notes of apricot nectar mimosa
petals and tuscan cypress
that's why uh our plugin of the week for
this week is the bed and bath and body
works
uh wallflowers signature collection
twilight woods
2-pack refill boom
all right so back in back in 2009 when
we got started with this podcast we
we were kind of looking to the future
because that's what what this podcast
was about was was
being smart people looking to the future
and uh and so way back then we put
together
a time capsule um
that smells like the beer from yesterday
uh
it does no really so so we don't really
remember what's in here
but uh but we're gonna read these these
predictions that we made
from uh from back in 2009 about what the
world would be like
when when we were here in 20 2013.
it's a good thing someone else is
unfolding these because microphone
all right prediction number one jquery
will need to come out with a web app
framework in order to remain relevant
uh is john dalton in here somewhere
oh fuse.js will be released
oh yeah
we will definitely have modules in
javascript
i i don't i don't i don't think i should
wait
paul's 15 minutes of fame will be over
uh yeah i don't know who wrote that hard
to say
uh apple
apple will totally cave on that whole
flash thing
last one last one all right we weren't
very even about this but that's that's
all right
just comp seems like a nice idea but the
ajax experience has way too much
developer mindshare for it to ever take
off
sickburn all right so
uh we just wanted to shout a thank you
to all the people who helped make
yayquery such a success uh kohitre was
our illustrator on our site you'll see a
bunch of these fantastic illustrations
of mystical magical creatures thank you
very much gohitre he's awesome
snover who did our video editing a lot
of the stuff you saw from the montage
that was
fantastically good after we fired alex
for doing such a
great job i edited the montage i edited
his edits
um thank you to john neal who made all
this awesome music
if you uh it's great um if you just
google uh
jquery music you'll find a band page of
the entire soundtrack
uh the songs are incredible um and uh
last of all we want to thank you thank
you for having us thank you for
music or something right then we'll walk
off stage too
and then we'll slowly come back and get
our laptops
quietly
you